ان تفرح لخساره خصمك هذا امر طبيعي ويحصل
في الرياضه والسياسه ايضا لكن ان تفرح
لخساره منتخبك فهذا الامر استثنائيه
وبحاجه للتوقف عنده ايرانيون فرحوا جدا
لبن احتفلوا بخساره منتخب بلادهم وخروجه
من مونديال قطر وامام من امام المنتخب
الامريكي العدو اللدود للنظام الايراني
فبعد خساره المنتخب الايراني امام نظيره
الامريكي في اخر مبارياته الموندياليه شهد
ايرانيون يحتفلون بهذه النتيجه في مقاطع
فيديو تم تداولها على نطاق واسع في مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعيه كهذه الصور التي
ستتابعها الان من العاصمه طهران
[تصفيق]
ليس هذا فحدث بل وصلت ببعض المشجعين
الايرانيين الشامتين بخساره منتخب بلادهم
الى رفع العلم الامريكي اثناء الخروج
للاحتفال بالخساره في اصفهان
[موسيقى]
اكثر من ذلك صدى خساره المنتخب الايراني
والتشفي بخروجهم على يد المنتخب الامريكي
وصل الى مسقط راس الفتاه الكرديه ماسه
امينه التي اندلعت الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
الايرانيه عقبه مقتلها على يد ما تسمى
بشرطه الاخلاق وتظهر الصور اطلاق البعض
للالعاب الناريه احتفالا بالهدف الامريكي
في مرمى منتخب بلادهم
[موسيقى]
المناطق الكرديه الايرانيه خرجت للرقص
والاحتفال بالدبكات الكرديه الشعبيه كما
حصل في سلندج ومهابات في هذه الصور
فلتبعها
[موسيقى]
الاخوان